mayor Suarez how would you clean up this
mess that Graham forced him to leave
what would you look it's actually not
that difficult right um you just cannot
Implement socialist policies right so
what what what happened what have we
done in Miami that's very different from
a lot of these cities right first is we
never got into the defund police
movement never this no that was never a
thing in Miami I'm not contrary we
actually increased funding for police
officers we have more officers than
we've ever had in our history so this
nonsense of defund police never happened
secondly and you see it manifesting
itself in that video the concept of no
cash bail right where you get arrested
and then you're back on the street you
don't even have to post bail
um and you're back on the street there's
no consequence there's no consequence to
committing crime right we live in a
society of laws there's supposed to be a
consequence when you break the law right
you you go to jail and then you have to
stand for trial et cetera et cetera when
you take away all those things because
you because you want to be sympathetic
what you end up doing is you have a
situation where now CVS yes walk how
many how many articles have we seen of
CVS and Walgreens and people shuddering
saying hey look the loss is greater than
the gain right so so who gets hurt so
now you're trying to you're trying to be
sympathetic to the person who's
committing crime and what you're
ultimately doing is you're diminishing
the quality of life of every single
other citizen we have this issue a lot
with homelessness right you want to be
very Humane with the homeless they're
human beings absolutely you have to be
Humane in the treatment of homeless but
you also have to understand that they
their actions impact everybody else and
so there are things that you know were
previously legal for the homeless to do
in the city of Miami that we changed
through Federal uh laws and you know
federal case where before they could
basically defecate and urinate in public
they call them life-sustaining
activities and they weren't even
required to go to a bathroom if there
was a bathroom within a certain feet
distance right things that you and I
couldn't do we couldn't just go outside
pull our pants down and go to the
bathroom right we get arrested for a
decent exposure so there was almost like
this sort of two-tiered system and and
so for us we never got into no cash bail
we never got into defund police we
increased funding for our police
officers we maintained Law and Order
when the George Floyd protest happened
net things never got out of control in
Miami because I said look there's a line
here right the line is we're not going
to let you harm people's property and
we're not going to let you harm people
and We're Not Gonna Let You harm police
officers if you try to do any of those
things we're going to arrest you we're
going to hold you accountable and we did
and so there was no antifa there was
none of that came here everybody to the
extent that they might have been here on
day one they were gone
um and so we had very little arrest uh
we were able to manage that very
intelligently and so and then I think
there's two other pieces right
to crime prevention we have the lowest
unemployment rate in America
full stop okay highest wage growth in
America full stop so and and these are
qualitative rankings but we're ranked
the happiest city in America and the
healthiest city in America so it turns
out if you're happy you're healthy
you're working and there's police
officers guess what you're not doing
committing violent crime or committing
crime right so it's not like a super
complex formula right it's it's sort of
basic and we've gotten away from it
because we've let these sort of
socialist ideologies
um which for me I think the biggest
danger in in the world is communism and
socialism because my parents got kicked
out of their country of birth when a
leader there said give us all your
property give us all your businesses and
don't worry we'll make everybody equal
and he did he made everybody equally
poor and equally miserable and thanks
Fidel yeah yeah and that and you so you
but by the way it's the easiest sell in
politics so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]